When the COVID-19 pandemic was declared in March 2020, many people headed home to shelter in place and expected that they would return to their offices and schools within a few weeks. None of us could have imagined how different the world would look one year later, especially that more than 500,000 Americans and 2.5 million people around the world would die from complications of COVID-19. Along with the physical toll of the coronavirus, the pandemic's economic and social, social consequences have caused what some people are calling a second pandemic of mental health concerns, as Americans have dealt with lost jobs, lack of child care, social isolation,
当COVID-19大流行在2020年3月宣布时，许多人回家就地避难，并预计他们将在几周内返回办公室和学校。我们谁也没有想到一年后的世界会有多大不同，尤其是超过50万美国人和全球250万人将死于COVID-19的并发症。除了冠状病毒造成的身体伤害外，大流行的经济和社会后果还引发了有些人所说的心理健康问题第二次大流行，因为美国人一直在应对失业、缺乏儿童保育、社交隔离，
and the illness and death of loved ones. APA's stress in America survey has been tracking this mental health toll over the course of the pandemic. Where are we now? How is our mental and our physical health one year in? Now that vaccines are providing some hope for an end of the How are we feeling about returning to our pre-pandemic lives? And what can each of us do that is healthy to ease our stress and anxiety in the face of continuing uncertainty about the future? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Vale Wright, a clinical psychologist and the senior director of
以及亲人的生病和死亡。美国心理协会（APA）的“美国压力”调查一直在跟踪大流行期间的这种心理健康代价。我们现在在哪里？经历了一年，我们的身心健康如何？既然疫苗为大流行的结束带来了一些希望，我们对回归大流行前生活的感觉如何？在面对对未来的持续不确定性时，我们每个人可以做些什么来缓解压力和焦虑？欢迎收听美国心理协会的旗舰播客《心理学说话》，该节目探讨了心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是临床心理学家兼高级总监瓦莱丽·赖特博士
of healthcare innovation here at APA. As a spokesperson for the association, Dr. Wright has given more than 100 interviews over the past year about the mental health consequences of COVID-19, including stress, anxiety, and loneliness, and offered advice on how to cope and build resilience. She has been a calm and reassuring voice to many as she has offered evidence-based advice on how to navigate the challenges we have all faced during this most unusual and stressful year. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Wright. Thanks for having me. I just mentioned our Stress in America survey in the introduction. We have a new report coming out on March 11th with fresh
APA的医疗保健创新部门。作为该协会的发言人，赖特博士在过去一年中就COVID-19的心理健康后果（包括压力、焦虑和孤独感）接受了100多次采访，并就如何应对和建立韧性提供了建议。在这个极不寻常和压力重重的年份里，她为许多人提供了一个冷静和令人安心的声音，并就如何应对我们都面临的挑战提供了循证建议。谢谢你今天加入我们，赖特博士。谢谢邀请我。我刚才在引言中提到了我们的“美国压力”调查。我们将于3月11日发布一份新报告，其中包含新鲜的
data on how Americans' physical and mental health have fared over the past year. Can you tell us, in general terms, what it found? Yeah. What we found in this report was that, you know, going a year now into this pandemic, and adults are consistently reporting extremely high levels of stress. and that this is actually leading to engaging in some pretty unhealthy coping behaviors in order to manage that stress. And that certainly has us really concerned. And so what are the outcomes then if they're engaging in unhealthy behaviors? What's happening? So what we're seeing is people are reporting undesired weight changes probably related to unhealthy eating habits, disrupted sleep, being less active.
关于美国人身心健康在过去一年中表现的数据。你能用概括性的语言告诉我们它的发现吗？是的。我们在本报告中发现的是，你知道，进入这个大流行的第一年，成年人持续报告极高的压力水平。这实际上导致他们采取一些相当不健康的应对行为来管理这些压力。这确实让我们非常担忧。那么，如果他们参与不健康的行为，结果会怎样？发生了什么？所以我们看到的是，人们报告了不希望看到的体重变化，这可能与不健康的饮食习惯、睡眠被打乱、活动减少有关。
And one of the most concerning is increases in alcohol intake. And when you take these together, they start to form a pattern of the ways in which people just are not, A, following the advice we're trying to give them, but are really, you know, just failing to engage in the kinds of behaviors we would hope to shore up their emotional well-being. And if this continues, the greatest concern, of course, is that it could lead to long-term negative physical and mental health consequences. Have these outcomes been distributed evenly across groups, or are there particular groups of people or members of specific demographics that have been having a more difficult time this year? You know, since the beginning of the pandemic, we've really seen, again, this consistent pattern of four really vulnerable groups. Those groups are parents with children under the age of 18, individuals from communities of color, essential workers, including frontline health care workers, and younger adults. These four groups are just reporting some of the highest levels of stress, some of the worst outcomes, and certainly are individuals that we as a country need to be concerned about. For those listeners who might recognize themselves in some of these statistical areas that we're talking about, what should they do to adopt more healthy habits and cope in more healthy and productive ways?
其中最令人担忧的是酒精摄入量的增加。当你把这些结合在一起时，它们开始形成一种模式，即人们只是没有，A，遵循我们试图给他们的建议，而是真的，你知道，只是未能参与我们希望用来支持他们情绪健康的各种行为。如果这种情况继续下去，最大的担忧当然是它可能导致长期的身心健康负面后果。这些结果是否在各个群体中均匀分布，还是某些特定群体或特定人口统计成员今年过得更艰难？你知道，自大流行开始以来，我们确实再次看到了这四类真正弱势群体的持续模式。这些群体是：家有18岁以下孩子的父母、有色人种社区的个人、包括一线医护人员在内的基本工作者，以及年轻成年人。这四个群体报告了最高的压力水平、最糟糕的一些结果，而且绝对是我们作为国家需要关注的个人。对于那些可能在我们正在谈论的这些统计领域中认出自己的听众，他们应该怎么做才能养成更健康的习惯，并以更健康和更有成效的方式应对？
Well, I think the first needs to come from a sense of awareness, an awareness that no matter what your situation is, nobody's immune to what's happening right now and that this is stressful. And if we can kind of just acknowledge that things are stressful and that we can legitimately feel that way, I think that actually opens up some space to really identify, okay, what is one or two areas that I could start making small changes? And then it's about kind of thinking about what those things are. We often beat ourselves up because we aren't successful at our goals because we only rely on our willpower, as if we can just wheel ourselves into changing behavior. And really what we need to do is change our environments. Put behavioral goals in place that are really attainable, and then we can build off of those small successes. What about the parents of young school-aged children who are among the most stressed out but also the most pressed for time? Is there any special advice for them?
嗯，我认为首先需要有一种觉悟感，一种意识到无论你的处境如何，没有人能对现在发生的事情免疫，而且这确实是有压力的。如果我们能够承认事情确实有压力，并且我们可以合法地产生这种感觉，我认为这实际上为真正确定“好吧，我可以开始做出微小改变的一两个领域是什么？”腾出了一些空间。然后就是思考这些事情是什么。我们经常因为未能实现目标而责备自己，因为我们只依靠我们的意志力，就好像我们能用意志力强迫自己改变行为一样。而实际上我们需要做的是改变我们的环境。制定真正可实现的行动目标，然后我们可以建立在这些小成功之上。那些最感压力但也最缺时间的学龄儿童父母呢？对他们有什么特别的建议吗？
Yeah, I think parents really need to do a couple different things. One is, are you asking for help from the right people and at the right times? Are there things that maybe your kids could be doing that they're not? Like some small developmentally appropriate chores around the house to take some of that burden off? Is your partner, if you have one, are you on the same page about who should be doing what and how to trade off tasks and how to have each other's back when somebody needs to take a break? And then you need to ask yourself, are there some things I can let go of? Whether that's unrealistic expectations, so how you should be feeling or concerns about too much device time, even though that may be a lifesaver for you right now. and just maybe saying no to some of the things that really you can let go of.
是的，我认为父母确实需要做几件不同的事情。一是，你是否在正确的时间向正确的人寻求帮助？有没有什么事是你的孩子可以做而他们现在没做的？比如在家里做一些适合他们发展阶段的小零活，来减轻一些负担？你的伴侣（如果你有的话），你们在谁应该做什么、如何分担任务以及当一个人需要休息时如何互相支持方面，是否达成了共识？然后你需要问自己，有没有什么事情我可以放手？无论是对你应该有什么感觉的不切实际的期望，还是对花太多时间看电子设备的担忧，尽管这现在可能是你的救命稻草。或许只是对一些你真的可以放手的事情说不。
So how do we change our environment in ways that will make it easier for us to do things that are healthy? Well, we have to sort of identify where some of our problem areas are, right? So if you're that kind of person that you know is maybe having that extra glass of wine at the evening, that making you uncomfortable, try not keeping so much wine in the house. If it's not there, it's really hard to actually engage in it. If you're having trouble sleeping, whether that's going to bed at a regular time, set yourself an alarm. An alarm about an hour before you'd think is the back time for you to go to sleep, so you can start winding down. That means turning off devices and maybe doing some soothing activities and just preparing yourself for sleep.
那么我们如何以使我们更容易做健康事情的方式改变我们的环境呢？嗯，我们必须找出我们的一些问题所在，对吧？所以如果你是那种你知道晚上可能多喝了一杯葡萄酒，这让你感到不舒服的人，试着不要在家里存放那么多葡萄酒。如果它不在那里，你其实很难去喝它。如果你睡眠有困难，不管是按时上床睡觉，给自己设个闹钟。一个在你认为该睡觉前大约一个小时的闹钟，这样你就可以开始放松了。这意味着关掉电子设备，也许做一些舒缓的活动，为睡眠做准备。
Similar in the morning, if you're hitting the snooze button over and over and over again, put your phone or your alarm far away from your bed so that you actually have to get up and go turn it off. So those are the kinds of behavioral things we're talking about. It's really helpful if you can incorporate others in your goals as well. So finding somebody who like you maybe wants to get out of the house a bit more and take walks. Can you guys put that on your schedule and then adhere to it? You know, really agree to meet because you know that the other person is depending on you. So those are the kinds of things that you can start off small and again have some decent successes that again build on each other and make you feel like you can be even more. effective. What about people who have been trying to work the way out of these behaviors and they're just not succeeding? How do they know when it's time to reach for outside help? You know, historically, we've always said that the red flag to reach for outside help was when your feelings and your behaviors are really interfering with your ability to function in a significant way. So typically that means, you know, really being unable to work or not being very effective at work,
早晨也一样，如果你一次又一次地按贪睡按钮，把你的手机或闹钟放在远离你床的地方，这样你实际上必须起床去关掉它。所以这些就是我们所说的行为方面的事情。如果你能把其他人也纳入你的目标中，那真的很有帮助。比如找一个可能像你一样想多出门走走并散步的人。你们能把这个安排在日程表上并坚持下去吗？你知道，真正同意见面，因为你知道另一个人在指望你。所以这些就是你可以从小事做起的事情，并且再次取得一些不错的成功，这些成功又会相互叠加，让你觉得自己可以更加有效。对于那些一直试图摆脱这些行为却没有成功的人来说，他们怎么知道什么时候该寻求外部帮助？你知道，从历史上看，我们总是说寻求外部帮助的危险信号是，当你的感受和行为在很大程度上干扰了你的功能时。所以通常这意味着，你知道，真的无法工作或者在工作不是很有效，
not being able to take care of yourself or your kids or if you're a young adult, not being able to go to school. But I think at this point, we really need to revise that advice and just say at any point and at any time, it's perfectly accepted to go seek out professional help, in particular in these sorts of areas around behaviors, because psychologists can really help you identify what are those steps that need to be taken in order to be more effective. And then, again, can hold you accountable because they'll follow up and see how you're doing. and then help troubleshoot with you on how to make different changes. And yes, sometimes we can do that on our own, but what's really beneficial from a professional is that, one, all the time gets to be about you.
无法照顾自己或孩子，或者如果你是一个年轻人，无法去上学。但我认为在这一点上，我们真的需要修改这个建议，只需说在任何时候，寻求专业帮助都是完全可以接受的，特别是在这些行为方面的领域，因为心理学家真的可以帮助你确定需要采取哪些步骤才能更有效。然后，他们还可以通过跟进和查看你的情况来让你承担责任，然后与你一起解决如何做出不同改变的问题。是的，有时我们可以靠自己做到这一点，但从专业人士那里得到的真正好处是，第一，所有的时间都是关于你的。
It's not a reciprocal relationship, so you don't actually have to worry about how they feel. And so that really allows you to focus on yourself and to get the help that you need. As one of APA's leading spokespeople throughout the pandemic, you've talked to many, many reporters about, some of the coping behaviors that they've been hearing about and observing. What are some of the more creative behaviors you've encountered through the course of the year? I think, certainly I've heard a fair amount of different sorts of things, obviously stress baking was the large story for a while. You know, I kind of enjoyed talking with people about this nostalgic feeling that people have, that they want to watch old movies and old TV shows to kind of and listen to old music from their childhood to bring them back to happier times.
这不是一种互惠关系，所以你实际上不必担心他们的感受。所以这真的能让你专注于自己并获得你需要的帮助。作为大流行期间APA的主要发言人之一，你曾与许多记者交谈过，关于他们听到和观察到的一些应对行为。你在这一年中遇到了一些什么更有创意的行为？我想，当然我听到相当多各种各样的事情，显然有一段时间“压力烘焙”是一个大新闻。你知道，我挺喜欢和人们谈论这种怀旧的情绪，人们想要看老电影和老电视剧，听他们童年的老音乐，以此把他们带回更快乐的时光。
I think for me, one of the more interesting developments has been around this concept of Zoom fatigue and the ways in which technology can play a pretty significant role, but how also it isn't a panacea and we can't overly rely on it to fix everything. One of my favorite research studies that's come out is that people talk 15% louder on Zoom calls and video conference. and calls, and that it takes that much more energy, and that's part of what contributes to that Zoom fatigue. And in our household, the joke is that I talk much louder than 15% when I'm on my Zoom calls and drive everybody pretty crazy. You know, Zoom is a challenge in itself because if you were in a meeting with people,
我认为对我来说，一个更有趣的发展是围绕着“Zoom疲劳”这个概念，以及技术可以扮演相当重要角色的方式，但它也不是万灵药，我们不能过分依赖它来解决一切。我最喜欢的研究之一是，人们在Zoom通话和视频会议上的说话声音比平时大15%，这需要更多的能量，这也是导致Zoom疲劳的一部分原因。在我们家里，开玩笑的说法是，当我开Zoom会议时，我说话声音比大15%还要大得多，把大家都搞得快疯了。你知道，Zoom本身就是一个挑战，因为如果你和人们在一个会议中，
you could talk over each other, you could have side conversations. And Zoom doesn't let you do that. So it's really, in a sense, imposing a kind of discipline on us. Do you think that might be good in the long run? I think it could be good. I mean, one of the challenges is even with a Zoom call, people don't like silence. So even though you can't talk over each other, it doesn't stop people necessarily from trying. And I think that, you know, what it's really demonstrated is how artificial it comes across when we're trying to have these large meetings, right?
你可以压倒对方说话，你可以有旁白对话。而Zoom不允许你这样做。所以从某种意义上说，它对我们强加了一种纪律。你认为从长远来看这可能是件好事吗？我认为这可能是件好事。我的意思是，其中一个挑战是，即使在Zoom通话中，人们也不喜欢沉默。所以即使你不能压倒对方说话，也并不一定能阻止人们尝试。而且我认为，你知道，它真正展示的是当我们试图开这些大型会议时，它是多么的不自然，对吧？
So you're maintaining this total sustained eye contact, which we never do in real meetings. In real meetings, we're looking at one person maybe. we're looking at our phone. You're constantly looking at yourself as well. And so you're asking yourself, you know, is that really what my mouth looks like when I talk? And so it just it requires a lot more effort and concentration. And when you do them back to back to back without any breaks, it's just exhausting. One of the other behaviors I've read about quite a bit is the fake commute. What is that? And how is that helping people? Yeah, I heard about that one a while back. and it seems to have made a resurgence.
所以你要保持这种完全持续的眼神交流，这我们在真正的会议中从不这样做。在真正的会议中，我们可能看着一个人。我们看着我们的手机。你也一直在看着你自己。所以你在问自己，你知道，这就是我说话时嘴巴的样子吗？所以这需要更多的精力和集中力。当你一个接一个地开会而没有任何休息时，这简直太累人了。我读过的另一个经常被提及的行为是“假通勤”。那是什么？它是如何帮助人们的？是的，我前段时间听说过这个，它似乎又死灰复燃了。
It's this idea of, you know, again, I think it puts some structure and routine in our lives when we have a commute. It represents the beginning and the end of our workday, right, in a really concrete way that we've lost now that so many of us are working from home in the same place that we live. And so I think what the fake commute does is bringing this mental structure to the beginning of your day. So it can look like, you know, just walking out of your house, taking a trip around the block and then coming back. And it just gives you, I think, some mental time to prepare and set yourself for your workday. Same thing at the end of the day. It really provides these, I think, bookends to allowing us to really let go and have some boundaries around our work that we've lost. Based on your expertise in human behavior, what do you think the longer term consequences of this year of stress and anxiety will be? Is the concern that a second pandemic is coming? Is that warranted?
这就是那种，你知道的，我认为通勤确实在我们的生活中建立了一些结构和常规。它以一种非常具体的方式代表了我们工作日的开始和结束，现在我们许多人在我们生活的地方工作，这种感觉已经失去了。所以我认为“假通勤”所做的是在你的的一天开始时带来这种心理结构。这看起来可能像，你知道，只是走出家门，绕着街区走一圈然后回来。我认为它只是给你一些心理时间来为你的工作日做准备和设定心态。一天结束时也是如此。我认为它确实提供了这些首尾呼应，让我们真正放手，并在我们的工作中建立一些我们已经失去的边界。基于你对人类行为的专业知识，你认为今年压力和焦虑的长期后果是什么？第二次大流行即将到来的担忧是有根据的吗？
You know, I think it's hard to predict the future, but I will say that if past behavior is the best predictor of future behavior, then these results from the stress in America surveys over the past year suggest that we could be in pretty significant trouble. That despite the amount of advice that us and others are giving, people are just really struggling with something that none of us were ever prepared to deal with for this sustained period of time. And so I think that we really need to be having larger conversations about our mental health and our emotional well-being in a way that hasn't gotten elevated yet so that we can start engaging in better coping behaviors. And that doesn't look just like going to psychotherapy because that's not a solution for everybody. But it's about really meeting people where they're at, whether that's in the workplace, in the schools, in churches, in wherever the case may be, I think we've really need to start having more of these conversations and reaching out to each other and asking each other really, you know, how are we doing today? Is the fact that we're hitting a one-year anniversary significant in the sense that people
你知道，我认为很难预测未来，但我会说，如果过去的行为是未来行为的最佳预测指标，那么过去一年来“美国压力”调查的这些结果表明，我们可能会陷入相当重大的麻烦中。尽管我们和其他人给出了多少建议，人们仍然在艰难地应对我们中没有一个人准备好在这么长一段时间内处理的事情。所以我认为我们真的需要以一种尚未提升的高度来开展关于我们心理健康和情绪健康的更大规模的对话，这样我们才能开始采取更好的应对行为。这不仅仅是去看心理治疗，因为那不是所有人的解决方案。而是真正走到人们所在的地方，无论是在工作场所、学校、教堂还是任何地方，我认为我们真的需要开始进行更多这样的对话，并向彼此伸出援手，真正地问对方，你知道，我们今天过得怎么样？我们迎来一周年纪念日这一事实是否重要，因为人们
may be reacting even more strongly to the realization that, oh, my God, it's really been a whole year that we've been living like this? Yeah, we know from the research on trauma and PTSD that anniversaries can be pretty significant triggers for individuals who've experienced some level of threats. And so it wouldn't surprise me that people are having a particularly hard time right now. I think it brings on a sense of reflection and reflection can be good. But it's also about our mindset a little bit and having some balance. So I'm hearing a lot of discussion about all the negatives that have happened over the last year and how people have felt like they quote unquote lost a year. And while it's true that we have lost many milestones, people, jobs,
可能会对“天哪，我们这样生活真的已经整整一年了”这种认识做出更强烈的反应？是的，我们从关于创伤和创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的研究中知道，周年纪念日对于经历过某种程度威胁的个人来说可能是相当重要的触发点。所以人们现在过得特别艰难，我一点也不觉得奇怪。我认为这带来了一种反思感，反思可以是好的。但这也是关于我们的一点心态和保持一些平衡。我听到很多关于过去一年发生的所有负面事情的讨论，以及人们如何觉得他们“引述”失去了“一年”。虽然确实我们失去了许多里程碑、人、工作、
etc., I do think that there has been gains that we've seen in the last year that people can look on and feel some gratitude for. I think the most important being how we, I believe, have come to reevaluate the importance of relationships, both within our family, but with our friends and with our coworkers. And I do hope that some of that can continue on, that we continue to prioritize and really value family over things and the things that we realize we could live without for a whole year. And then, you know, just again, re-evaluate how we want to live our lives going forward so that we continue to live lives worth living. Yeah, it's real interesting. how we've become more intimate with the people who are our coworkers. We see their homes. They're
等，但我确实认为，我们在过去一年中看到了人们可以回顾并感恩的收获。我认为最重要的是我们如何重新评估人际关系的重性，无论是在我们家庭内部，还是与我们的朋友和同事。我确实希望其中一些能够延续下去，我们继续优先考虑并真正珍视家庭胜过物质，以及那些我们意识到没有它们也能活整整一年的东西。然后，你知道，只是再次重新评估我们希望如何生活下去，以便我们继续过上值得生活的生活。是的，这真的很有趣，我们如何与作为我们同事的人变得更加亲密。我们看到他们的家。他们在
on Zoom's and their kids come running in with, oh, mom, I just, you know, skin my knee or things are just happening or the plumber is at the door. I've got to go. It's just really a completely different feeling. And I think we're going to see workplace changes. I mean, what are you anticipating that the workplace will be like when the pandemic is declared over? Yeah, I think it's going to really vary depending on probably the field you're in and even maybe the area of the country that you're in. But I do think work is fundamentally never going to look quite the same. We have demonstrated that I think people can effectively work in a more flexible manner. And whether that means working from home more frequently, whether that means working slightly more flex hours so that you can take time maybe in the middle of the day to address things that before you would have felt like you couldn't.
Zoom会议上，他们的孩子跑进来喊着，哦，妈妈，我只是，你知道，擦破了膝盖，或者事情正在发生，或者水管工在门口。我得走了。这真的是一种完全不同的感觉。而且我认为我们将看到工作场所的变化。我的意思是，你预计当大流行宣布结束时，工作场所会是什么样？是的，我认为这会根据你所处的领域甚至你所在的地区而有很大差异。但我确实认为工作从根本上永远不会完全一样。我们已经证明，我认为人们可以以更灵活的方式有效地工作。无论是更频繁地在家工作，还是稍微更有弹性地工作，这样你就可以在一天当中抽时间处理以前因为我们所有人对工作应该是怎样的严格看法而觉得不能做的事情。
you know, because of the strict ways that I think all of us had been thinking about how work is, quote, unquote, supposed to be. And I think a lot of those old notions have been demonstrated to be outdated, that they don't really reflect the real world that most of us are living in right now. And so I do think that using technology and having some flexibility and really prioritizing work-life balance in a better way will become more of the norm going forward for most people. One thing that people are thinking about more right now, since we have three very effective vaccines that are getting into people's arms, they're thinking, what's it going to be like when things start to return to normal? What did APA survey find about how people feel regarding the idea of going back to seeing friends, eating out, traveling, engaging in those activities where we're going to be seeing more people face-to-face again?
你知道，因为我们所有人都曾认为工作应该是什么样子的严格方式。我认为许多这些旧观念已被证明是过时的，它们并不能真正反映我们大多数人目前生活的现实世界。所以我确实认为，利用技术、拥有一些灵活性并以更好的方式真正优先考虑工作与生活的平衡，对大多数人来说将成为前进的常态。由于有三种非常有效的疫苗正在为人们接种，人们现在更多思考的一件事是，当事情开始恢复正常时会是什么样子？APA的调查发现，人们对于重新开始见朋友、外出吃饭、旅行、参与那些我们将更多面对面相聚活动的看法如何？
Yeah, I think we're seeing an interesting dichotomy, right, where there's this real desire to want to see our families and have things not look like they do right now, but there's a lot of anxiety about it as well. So we found that over nearly 50% of adults reported that they felt either uncomfortable or with returning to life how it was before the pandemic and reporting concerns about sort of reengaging in these one-to-one face-to-face kinds of conversations. And that held true, regardless of whether you'd actually had the vaccine or not. And I think that part of what's driving this anxiety is, again, this level of uncertainty that continues. Even as we have these three great vaccines, there's still a lot of uncertainty about what's going to happen with these new variants and how long will these vaccines last? And can someone be asymptomatic? And so in the face of all that uncertainty, we become really ineffective at making good. risk threat assessments. We have a tendency to either overestimate risk or underestimate risk.
是的，我认为我们看到了一个有趣的二分法，对吧？一方面非常渴望见到我们的家人，希望事情不要像现在这样，但另一方面对此也有很多焦虑。所以我们发现，近50%的成年人报告说，他们对于回归大流行之前的生活感到不舒服，并对重新参与这种一对一的面对面谈话表示担忧。无论你是否真的接种了疫苗，这一点都成立。我认为推动这种焦虑的部分原因再次是这种持续存在的不确定性。即使我们有了这三种伟大的疫苗，对于这些新变种会发生什么以及这些疫苗能持续多久，仍然有很多不确定性。无症状感染者会存在吗？所以在所有这些不确定性面前，我们在做出良好的风险威胁评估方面变得非常无能。我们倾向于高估风险或低估风险。
And that then translate into our behaviors. And we have to, you know, ask ourselves, you know, is it safe to see friends and family now? Is it safe to eat inside that restaurant? And having to make those decisions over and over and over again, one, it's exhausting. But two, you're always not sure if you're putting yourself and your family at risk. And so I think That's really what's driving a lot of this stress about reentry. And, yeah, I mean, you raised the question of how you navigate relationships with friends and family members who have different ideas about what it's okay to do now because there's just so much uncertainty. How best can people navigate making those decisions and where should they be getting their information so they know what risks are reasonable and what risks are now? Just not.
这随后转化为我们的行为。我们不得不，你知道，问自己，现在去看朋友和家人安全吗？在那家餐馆里面吃饭安全吗？不得不一次又一次地做出这些决定，第一，这很累人。但第二，你始终不确定自己是否让自己和家人处于危险之中。所以我认为这确实是推动这种重返社会的压力的原因。是的，我的意思是，你提出了如何与对现在可以做什么有不同想法的朋友和家人处理关系的问题，因为有太多的不确定性。人们如何最好地驾驭这些决定，他们应该从哪里获取信息，以便他们知道哪些风险是合理的，哪些风险是现在不行的。
Yeah, so certainly we want to be following the best scientific advice that we can find. So that's really institutions like the CDC and the WHO. And so following those sorts of recommendations is a good place to start. The second is, you know, one, really having some grace for yourself and for others as they were trying to make these decisions. I think we have a tendency to get judgmental just because somebody maybe sees something differently than we do. And instead of sort of approaching it with judgment, I think if we can approach it, with grace and that everybody really has their own level of risk that they're comfortable taking. And then you need to sit down with your family or whoever you know, you sort of interact with
是的，所以当然我们要遵循我们能找到的最佳科学建议。所以这实际上是像CDC和世卫组织这样的机构。因此，遵循这些类型的建议是一个好的开始。其次，你知道，第一，在试图做出这些决定时，对自己和他人多一点宽容。我认为我们有一种倾向，仅仅因为某人对事物的看法可能与我们不同，就会变得好为人师。如果我们能够带着宽容而不是评判的态度去接近它，并且每个人都有他们乐于承受的自己的风险水平。然后你需要和你的家人或任何你知道的人坐在一起，
and come up with a plan of what you're comfortable with based on your individual risk factors and where you, including where you live. And then just unapologly stick to it when someone challenges you on it. You can be firm, but friendly. And I think that's just the approach and flexible because as more information comes in, we need to be able to adapt and maybe make new choices. And that's perfectly okay. Maybe this is an unfair question, but what can we expect to see the next time APA goes out and surveys again? I mean, with the vaccines getting out there, should we start to see the stress levels drop? I know we'd like to, but do you think that it's likely based on your experience over the past year and just over time?
并根据你个人的风险因素和你的居住地，制定一个你感到舒服的计划。然后，当有人对你提出异议时，毫不羞愧地坚持下去。你可以坚定但友好。我认为这就是方法，而且要灵活，因为随着更多信息的进来，我们需要能够适应并可能做出新的选择。这完全没问题。也许这是一个不公平的问题，但下次APA出去再次调查时，我们可以期待看到什么？我的意思是，随着疫苗的推出，我们应该开始看到压力水平下降吗？我知道我们愿意，但根据你过去一年以及随着时间的经验，你认为这可能吗？
I think for some groups, we're likely to see the stress levels come down. It's going to be in particular, older adults. They report some of the lowest levels of stress in the first place, but I think for them, what's been most stressful has been the lack of interacting with family. And I think one of the first things we're going to see with the vaccines really now is the ability for small families to come back together for grandparents to see their grandchildren. I do really continue to worry for the four vulnerable groups that we talked about before. I think we've also seen in our research that as kids are going back to school, parents reporting lower levels of stress.
我认为对于某些群体，我们很可能会看到压力水平下降。特别是老年人。他们首先报告的压力水平最低，但我认为对他们来说，最 stressful 的一直是缺乏与家人的互动。我认为随着疫苗的真正推出，我们首先看到的事情之一就是小家庭重新聚在一起，祖父母看到他们的孙子孙女。我确实继续为我们之前谈到的四个弱势群体感到担忧。我认为我们在研究中也看到，随着孩子们重返学校，父母报告的压力水平降低了。
So the sooner we can get schools safely reopened, I think will help that group. But for individuals from communities of color and essential workers, I have strong concerns for their mental well-being going forward. If we don't make some systemic changes, these are not individual levels. changes, but changes within our health care system within our, obviously, our social system, as well as ensuring that people have resources that they've lost. I think unless those things really happen at a more population health level, then we're going to continue to see individuals really reporting that they're struggling. On balance, more optimism or more pessimism right now? I, you know, I've always leaned towards pessimism, obviously, I said it first.
因此，我们能越快安全地重新开放学校，我认为就会对这个群体有所帮助。但对于有色人种社区的个人和基本工作者，我对他们未来的心理健康有强烈的担忧。如果我们不做一些系统性的改变，这些不是个人的水平。改变，而是我们医疗系统内部的改变，显然还有我们的社会系统，以及确保人们拥有他们失去的资源。我认为，除非这些事情真正在更广泛的人口健康层面上发生，否则我们将继续看到个人真正报告他们正在挣扎。总的来说，现在是更乐观还是更悲观？我，你知道，我一直倾向于悲观，显然，我先说了。
That was such a Freudian slip on my part. I'm an optimist, darn it. No, I'm feeling optimistic. You know, I think that there are more people out there that want the vaccine that don't, although I do think vaccine hesitancy is still an issue. And I think that it needs to be addressed again at a larger level and within the communities that community leaders come forward. They're vocal and their visual about, you know, accepting the vaccine and providing that opportunity. And I think hopefully that these conversations will continue and maybe even elevate now that we're moving forward and we're less focused just on our physical health. I think the natural pivot will have to be to talking more broadly about our mental health.
那真是我口误。我是个乐观主义者，该死。不，我感到很乐观。你知道，我认为外面有更多的人想要疫苗而不是不想要，尽管我认为疫苗犹豫仍然是一个问题。我认为这需要在更大的层面上解决，并在社区内部让社区领导人挺身而出。他们在接种疫苗方面大声疾呼、以身作则，并提供这种机会。我认为希望这些 conversations 会继续下去，甚至可能在我们前进的现在得到提升，我们不再仅仅关注我们的身体健康。我认为自然的转向将不得不更广泛地谈论我们的心理健康。
And you can't fix something until you acknowledge and are aware that it's an issue. And so I think that's where we need to get to. Well, thank you for joining us today, Dr. Wright. It's been a pleasure talking with you as always. And I hope to see you in the office again. of these days. Yes, let's hope so. You can find links to APA's COVID-19 information and resources, as well as our Stress in America surveys on our website at APA.org. And you can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology there or on speakingof psychology.org. Or you can get them on Apple,
在你承认并意识到这是一个问题之前，你是无法解决它的。所以我认为这就是我们需要到达的地方。好吧，谢谢你今天加入我们，赖特博士。一如既往，与你交谈非常愉快。我希望能在办公室再次见到你。这些天。是的，让我们希望如此。你可以在我们的网站APA.org上找到APA的COVID-19信息和资源的链接，以及我们的“美国压力”调查。你可以在那里或者在speakingof psychology.org上找到《心理学说话》以前的剧集。或者你可以在Apple上获取它们，
Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology all one word at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condayan. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Stitcher，或者任何你获取播客的地方。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，请发电子邮件至speaking of psychology at APA.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，在APA.org。Speaking of Psychology由Lee Weinerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Condayan。感谢美国心理协会的收听。我是金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。